- It is believed that the first humans
settled North and South
America, or began to settle it,
about 15 to 16,000 years ago
and the mainstream theory
is that they came across
from northeast Asia,
across the Bering Strait, during
the last glaciation period,
when sea levels were lower
and there was a land bridge,
the famous Bering Land Bridge
connecting the two continents
and we have archeological
evidence of humans
in southern Chile as
early as 14,500 years ago
and as well in Florida as
early as 14,500 years ago.
So humans had migrated into,
and settled in the Americas
many, many, many thousands of years ago.
And like other places in the world,
they followed similar
development patterns.
The first evidence we
have of the development
of agriculture in the
Americas is about seven
to eight or nine thousand years ago
so once again, it coincides
with when agriculture,
we believe, started to emerge
in other parts of the world.
And the more archeological evidence
we find, we'll probably find dates that go
even further back than that, in fact,
I've seen some that go eight,
nine thousand years ago.
Now one misconception,
significant misconception,
about the Americas is that
when the Europeans colonized,
remember Columbus comes sailing in 1492,
looking for the East Indies
and then he bumps into this,
he actually doesn't bump
into the whole continent,
he bumps into an island
that's close to the continent,
but with that you start
having the beginning
of the European colonization
of the Americas,
roughly the last 500 years,
and one misconception
that folks often have
is, well it was maybe
sparsely populated, mainly by
hunter-gatherer nomadic people
and nothing could be
further from the truth.
The modern estimates of the
population of the Americas
at the time of the European colonization,
roughly around 1500 is
50-100 million people
and to put that in perspective,
so that's right around
there, that's about 10 to 20%
of the world population at that time.
The world population at that time
was about 500 million people
and given that the Americas is
about one third of the land,
if you don't count Antarctica,
it's not that different
of a population density
than the other continents,
and we have significant cities
that were in place in
the pre-Columbian era,
in the era before Columbus
and the European colonization.
For example, you might
have heard of the Aztecs,
this really, the core, the Mexica people,
the Mexica tribe, in many
ways the foundations,
of the Mexican people
pre-European colonization.
You might also be familiar
with the Mayan civilization,
one of the longest lasting
civilizations in, actually,
in history, they're famous for
one of the earliest cultures
where we have the hieroglyphics,
where we have writing.
You're probably familiar
with the Inca Empire
and yes, that is me on a recent trip
and at the time of the Inca Empire
it is believed that it was
possibly the largest empire
on the earth at that time,
incredibly complex structures
and social structures, they had.
Now what's often less talked about
are things like the Mississippian culture,
which was in North
America right over here.
The Mississippi River is named for them.
This if their famous city of Cahokia
near St. Louis and in there, in that peak,
it would have 40,000 people in it.
Around the world at that time,
at the time of the Mississippian culture,
there weren't many cities in the world
that had 40,000 people,
so it wasn't these,
just hunter-gatherers and
people who were nomadic,
there were sophisticated civilizations,
with sophisticated cultures
and dense population centers
and it had also been in
place for a long time,
similar, in timeframe, to
some of the great ancient
civilizations that we see in Mesopotamia,
the Indus Valley, and in China.
For example, the oldest
civilization we know of,
in Mesoamerica, is the Olmec civilization,
right over here, here's a few
of their artifacts they have.
If we go into the Andes,
near modern day Peru,
we have the Chavin
culture, right over there.
As you can see, a lot of these cultures,
at least the ones that I'm putting here,
and this is just a sample,
I'm sampling some around
North America, some around Mesoamerica,
and some in the Andes, and then
you can even go further back
and you can go to the Caral civilization,
and what's really interesting
about the Caral civilization
is some archeologists call
this the first civilization
and it's unclear whether they had,
whether they farmed grains and cereals
that we often associate
with civilizations, they use
their surplus crops to have a
more specialized labor force,
but they were a maritime
culture, even today
the coast of Peru is a
significant source of all of the,
or a good chunk of the
seafood in the world
but a significant culture developed there,
these are the remnants of their pyramids,
and they developed, we believe,
in the 4th millennium BCE,
so this is around the same time
as when Egypt first got
unified around Menes, by Menes,
or you have the first
Sumerians in Mesopotamia
and as far back as them you
have these Quipus knots,
which many archeologists
view as a form of writing,
it was a form of record-keeping
and it was even used
later on by the Incas.
So the big take away here, is to challenge
that misconception that the
Americas somehow were not as,
has populations and civilizations
like everything else,
it was only when the Europeans came in
that all of that started to happen, no.
Well before the Europeans came in,
North and South America had been settled,
agriculture developed
at a similar timescale,
significant, complex civilizations,
writing developed on a similar timescale,
but once you have the
European colonization,
some people say it was intentional,
it was probably a
combination of intentional
and just diseases that were
unfamiliar to the people here,
within 150 years, that 50
to 100 million population,
so now we're talking
about, roughly by 1650,
so you move a little bit forward in time,
the population had gone to
roughly six million people,
some people refer it to a genocide,
some people would say it's a combination
of an intentional extermination of people
plus just inadvertent
disease, whatever it is,
this was the significant decline
of a complex and diverse
set of populations.
This is just a small sample
of the major civilizations
that were there,
you had thousands of tribes
across North and South America
that had different cultures,
different languages,
different traditions
and different religions.